let's see rather a lot of ideas that I
disagree with perhaps the most
frightening was Hillary Clinton saying
she has a million good ideas for America
that we just can't afford you know we
can't afford Hillary Clinton's million
good ideas although Charlie Rangel is
trying to raise taxes enough to give her
the money she wants probably the most
dangerous idea we heard however came
from Barack Obama his insistence that we
just pull out of Iraq regardless of the
consequences without thinking about what
would happen if Iraq became a safe haven
for for al Qaeda a dangerous thought and
then compounding that by saying that he
would in his first year dignify Castro
Ahmed in echad Assad Kim jong-il some of
the great tyrants of our world with his
personal presence as president of the
United States that is something which is
also perhaps not as dangerous as it is
alarming and and disappointing